Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
17 Ağustos 1999.
Sabaha karşı,
büyük bir sarsıntıyla uyandım.
Büyük bir korkuyla
kendimi sokağa attım.
Evet, deprem olmuştu.
Depremin merkez üssünün
Gölcük'te olduğunu öğrenince,
hemen yola koyuldum;
çünkü annem ve kardeşlerim
Gölcük'te yaşıyorlardı.
Gölcük'e vardığımda,
görünen manzara korkunçtu.
Yıkılan binalar,
enkaz altında yardım çığlıkları,
şaşkınlık, çaresizlik.
Ailemi bir parkta buldum,
herkes şok içindeydi.
Evet,
45 saniye süren
Büyük Marmara Depremi'nin
bilançosu çok ağırdı.
18 bin kişi hayatını kaybetmişti,
24 bin kişi yaralanmıştı.
285 bin konut yıkılmış,
43 bin iş yeri yok olmuştu.
Bilim adamlarına göre,
olası Marmara Depremi...
Bilim adamlarına göre
Marmara Depremi,
olası İstanbul Depremi'nin habercisiydi.
Yine bilim adamlarına göre,
olası İstanbul Depremi'nin etkisi
Büyük Marmara Depremi'nin
dört ya da beş kat üstünde olacaktı.
Gölcük'te tanık olduklarım,
artçı depremler nedeniyle
Maçka Parkı'nda yaşadıklarım
bir birey ve şehir plancısı olarak
bir sorunun yanıtını
aramaya sevk etti beni.
O da,
olası bir depremde
İstanbul'da yeterli
toplanma alanları var mıydı?
İstanbul'da Kuzey ormanlarını saymazsak,
2 bin hektar,
yani 20 milyon metre kare açık alan var.
Olası bir depremde,
yaşayan nüfusun dörtte biri etkilense,
4 bin hektar, yani 40 milyon metre kare
açık alana ihtiyacımız var.
İvedilikle 2 bin hektar açık alanı
yaratmamız gerekiyor.
Ulaşılabilecek bir rakam mı?
2 bin hektar ne demek?
2 bin hektar,
2 Şişli ilçesi demek.
1 Bağcılar;
2 bin hektar,
3 Güngören demek.
4 hektar büyüklüğünde
500 adet Gezi Parkı demek.
2 bin hektar,
1 hektar büyüklüğünde
2 bin adet futbol sahası demek.
Düşünün,
İstanbul'da 1000 mahalle var,
her mahallede
2 adet futbol sahası yaratmalıyız.
Ne için?
Olası bir depremde çadır kurmak,
kendimizi güvence altına almak için.
Peki bu soruya,
temel soruya
"Bu alanları nerede, nasıl yaratacağız?"
bunun üzerinde tartışmaya başladım.
Tabii ki, İstanbul'un
en riskli alanlarından başlayacağız.
İstanbul'un en riskli alanı,
TEM ile E-5 arasındaki sarı bölge.
Toplam nüfusun %55'i,
iki yol arasında yaşıyor.
En yüksek riskli ve en az yeşil alanın
bulunduğu bölge, iki yol arasında.
İki yol arasında bir yol açma,
üçüncü yol açma fikri zihnimde gelişti.
Bu yol, belediyelerin en iyi yaptığı
iş olan karayolu olmamalıydı.
Bu yol, Yeşil Yol olmalıydı.
Küçükçekmece'yle Pendik arasında,
E-5 ile TEM'in arasında
50 km uzunluğunda,
200 metre genişliğinde bir Yeşil Yol.
Bu alanda riskli binalar yıkılacak,
yeniden tasarlanacak,
100 metrelik bant içerisinde
yeniden inşa edilecek.
Gerisi, gerisi açık alan olacak.
Parklar, kamusal alanlar
bu alanlarda yaratılacak.
Yani Yeşil Yol Projesi,
olası bir depremde
hem tahliye koridoru
hem de toplanma alanı
fonksiyonunu yüklenecek.
Fikrimi kamu yöneticileriyle paylaştım.
Bazıları,
"Çok iyi proje, çok iyi fikir;
ama gerçekleşmesi zor." dediler.
Bazıları,
"Ya zaten biz de E-5 ile TEM arasına
bir karayolu açmak istiyorduk,
ama bütçemiz olmadığı için
bunu yapamadık." dediler.
Fikrimi geliştirmek istedim.
Fikrimi, kurduğum atölyelere taşıdım.
İki tane atölye kurmuştuk İstanbul'da:
Tasarım Atölyesi Kadıköy,
Tasarım Atölyesi Kartal.
Bir de vizyonu çok önemsediğimiz için,
kentlerin büyük sorunlarını
stratejilerle çözeceğimize
inandığımız için,
Vizyon Atölyesi'ni kurmuştuk.
Vizyon Atölyesi'nin gündemine
Yeşil Yol'u aldık.
Tasarımcılarla mahallelileri
bir araya getirdik.
Onlarla birlikte Yeşil Yol fikrini
görünür kılmaya çalıştık.
Kendimize bir mahalle seçtik,
Kartal'da seçtiğimiz mahallede
mahallelilerle birlikte tasarımcılar
proje üretmeye başladılar.
Amacımız şuydu;
zaten atölyelerimizin de temel felsefesi,
bir sorun ortaksa,
herkesi çözümüne ortak etmemiz gerekiyor.
Tasarım düşüncesi yoluyla,
tasarımcılar ve mahalleliler
bir araya geldik.
Yeşil Yol'un üzerinde kalan
bazı bina sahipleri,
"Benim binamı yıkıyorsun.
Ben bunu kabul etmiyorum," dedi.
Ama süreç içerisinde,
karşılıkla empati içerisinde,
soruna ortak oldukları zaman,
"Ne zaman başlıyoruz?"
demeye başladılar.
Bugün Belediye Başkanına,
"Yeşil Yolumuz ne zaman açılacak?"
diye baskı yapmaya başladılar.
Mahallelilerle bu fikrimizi paylaştık,
aldığımız tepkiler çok olumluydu.
Fikrimizi özel sektörle
paylaşmaya çalıştık.
Özel sektöre projemizi anlattığımız zaman,
yatırımcıların
çok zeki insanlar olduğunu biliyoruz,
yeşil alanın, açık alanın katma değerinin
çok yüksek olduğunu bildikleri için,
"Bu projede varız" dediler.
Yeter ki,
bir kamu otoritesinin
bir kamu gücünün
bu projeyi yönetmesi gerekir.
Evet, aldığımız tepkiler çok olumluydu.
Bu tepkiler neticesinde
projemizi geliştirdik,
tasarılarımızı geliştirdik.
Yeşil Yol Projesi,
500 hektar büyüklüğünde
bir toplanma alanı yaratıyordu.
İhtiyacımız ne kadardı?
2000 hektar.
1500 hektarı nerede ve nasıl yaratacaktık?
Bu sorunun yanıtını
atölyelerde genç tasarımcılarla,
belediye başkanlarıyla,
özel sektör temsilcileriyle
aramaya başladık.
Bir şeyi keşfettik:
İstanbul'un vadileri ve su yolları.
Yani mavi ve yeşili,
bilineni yeniden keşfettik.
İstanbul'a
mavi ve yeşil bir örtü tasarladık.
Ortasında Yeşil Yolumuz,
kuzey güney yolunda,
doğu batı yönünde yollar açtık.
Böylelikle hedefimiz olan
2000 hektarın çok üzerine çıktık.
Mavi yeşil örtü, İstanbul'un üzerine
atmış olduğumuz bu örtü,
İstanbul'un yeniden kurgulanması,
İstanbul'un yeniden planlanması için
önemli bir altlık oluşturacağına inandık.
Evet.
Yeşil Yol Projesi;
bir iş birliği,
güç birliği projesi.
Yeşil Yol, ortak sorunların
ortak çözümlerin arandığı bir proje.
Yeşil Yol Projesi
anadolu kültürlerinin harmanlandığı
İstanbul'da;
imece, yani paylaşma geleneğinin,
yeniden canlandırılması projesi.
Hangi meslek grubundan olursanız olun,
hangi yaş grubundan olursanız olun,
bu projenin içerisinde
kendinize bir yer bulmalısınız.
Benim mahallemde iki futbol sahası var,
deyip bu sorundan kurtulamazsınız,
çünkü depreme nerede ve ne zaman
karşılaşacağınızı bilemezsiniz.
O nedenle, bu projeye herkesin
bir şekilde ortak olması gerekiyor.
Büyük Marmara Depremi'nin
üzerinden tam 19 yıl geçti.
Doğa bize 19 yıldır avans veriyor.
Daha ne kadar bu avansı verecek,
bilemeyiz.
O nedenle,
gelin birlik olalım.
Bu projenin içerisine bir şekilde girelim
ve İstanbul'u yeşil yollarla
birlikte örelim.
Teşekkürler.
(Alkış)